[Applause]
[Music]
combat talk with the king now that we
had Danny Garcia versus Shawn Porter and
the fight is over and the two combatants
lived up to what I thought they would
live up to now what we saw unfold in the
fight was uh Danny Garcia v Danny Garcia
and what we saw from Shawn Porter was
Shawn Porter was different Shawn Porter
has matured as a fighter Shawn Porter
stayed home and didn't box wild like he
normally does what he did was he stayed
in control because he learned very early
on Danny is sharp and Danny is powerful
so Danny hit him with shots then Shawn
had to stay discipline he had to stay
mindful and respectful of defense Danny
played how Danny plays he uh he got his
precision shots in his percentage was
higher than Shawn's and we all knew
Shawn volume will be higher the Danny's
but what we thought going in was Shawn
would be a little bit Wilder Shawn was
not wild Shawn was a champion Shawn
deserved to win that fight and he did
win that fight it went 12 rounds like I
said it was a majority decision like I
said but it wasn't in favor of Danny got
to give one caveat I'm a Danny fan I
love the camaraderie that he has with
his father
same thing with Sean but it's a little
bit different um and also I'm a little
bit biased so in saying that I expected
Danny to raise his game a little bit
more and he did he started out faster he
went at Shawn and in doing so he
definitely didn't expect Shawn to
counted the way Sean did Sean stayed
discipline in this in this mu Sean I
believe that he can you know beat a lot
of fighters
but the dizzy beat Errol Spence jr. no
you know that's where that train stops
so I salute you Shawn Porter for giving
us one hell of a fight last night I
salute you Danny Garcia for giving us
one hell of a fight
that was beautiful to watch I'm glad I
watched history and no one not even one
of you can walk with your head down even
the loser is a winner because I don't
believe that that night any person other
than Shawn Porter would have pulled that
off because he became exactly what he
needed to be to win that fight this
combat talk with the king see you next
week with Canelo vs triple G
[Applause]
[Music]